the problem is
that people don't understand the concept
of saving money
before you buy something i've talked
about this on my webcast there's a
incredibly funny but just a
golden nugget of a clip from saturday
night live
from years ago is when steve martin was
on the show oh gosh
and it's absolutely perfect uh it's
this couple is in the kitchen steve
martin and i can't remember
jane something or i think her name was
the uh and and they're in the
kitchen table fretting over their credit
card bills and what are we gonna do
where
all this debt and all of a sudden this
this guy shows up like off
comes on camera and he goes read my book
and he said because it's it's called
don't buy stuff you can't afford
and they're like what i don't understand
what does that mean
and look at page one
don't save money before you buy
something go
save money yep and he goes like
well wait a minute if i don't have the
money but i want something i can buy it
right
and he goes no you can't buy
really yep and he says but where are you
supposed to get all of this
saved money it's absolutely classic
sketch
yeah i'll never forget my my
my current doctor and favorite
medical doctor once said
danielle don't look at diets if you want
to lose weight
eat less he's less than exercise more
it's pretty simple
yeah and it's the same kind of that was
it we we were really
at a point at one point when i was a kid
where we were
really scratching to get by and
we were at the supermarket and we didn't
have enough money
and we had to put stuff back yeah and
i said to my mother because this was
there were no credit cards before 1970s
right so
here we are it's credit cards had just
kind of come come around
and i said why don't you just put it on
the credit card and she just looked at
me and she says
let me tell you something never ever
ever put food on a credit card ever
never borrow money to buy food because
that's a slippery slope
which ends potentially very badly i
never forgot that
but also when i was a kid there were no
auto loans
nope they didn't exist you had to save
the money
and go and actually buy the car now you
can take seven years
well it's it's it's come this far it's
because you know it's one of these
things where
everyone knows that borrowing money to
buy food and
leveraging up on your car and you know
on that note it's funny i was listening
to the radio a while ago
and they were talking about how there
was a such a steep decline in prices of
used
luxury cars and i mean luxury cars
lambos ferraris right
and they were down like 50 percent in a
year
and this was before covet this was when
the economy was good right
right and they said you know the prices
have gone from like
i'm just making up numbers but 300 000
to 150 000
and i was like how could that be i mean
that there's the economy's
okay yeah and the reason was that they
had
toughened up on the lending standards
for used car loans i was like
people are borrowing 300 grand by a
lambo
oh yeah their payments are like mortgage
payments
so it's one of these things where
everyone knows that this is
a bad way to go but it's all those
things where in the short term
there's a payoff and it's just like our
national debt it's just like
so many things that yeah yeah you've
been saying that
this is a problem for years and look
everything's fine
yes it's a problem in the long term
everybody says
but you know that could be a long long
way away but
what happens is you glue enough short
terms together and all of a sudden the
long term is today
[Music]